yes c'est moi qui fais ce bruit ça va
durer pendant toute la vidéo pour
changer un peu de mon appart voici un
très beau décor de noël que j'ai pas
fais moi-même là dans l'image il ya de
norman arias mois il ya aussi cette
fameuse espèce de sapins qui
malheureusement pour moi s'appelle
également normal et pourquoi on serait
pas plutôt norman fait des vidéos au je
m'occupais là j'ai pas le temps bonjour
les petits conifères
j'ai pas se faire remarquer mais quand
tu es un simple pacte agrandir pleine
nature avec tes potes c'est toujours un
plaisir d'être coupée pour noël au par
la cua ça à mon tour un peu ça c'est ma
place je me rends ma place à yas audio
gay ou gay da bahia bref noël tous les
ans c'est un moment magique
ah ça c'est clair par contre que tu es
10 ans 20 ans 30 ans ou plus tu vis pas
exactement de la même manière
donc voici noël sur nos âges simplement
cesser le même titre que la vidéo en
fête en fête à noël quand tu es enfant
tu as rien à faire juste eu commande et
tout arrive direct avec les gens et se
transforme pas en deux les verrous et
amazon quoi je suis pas d'accord avec
toi ton tout c'est juste des gens qui
m'aident si tous merci
[Musique]
je le sens pas je ne sais pas
faire le père noël je n'ai jamais pas
répéter je sais pas mais si bon jour que
moi je le père noël en fête est en fait
je fasse quoi j'ai bien dit paul je suis
fier du pôle nord est et ça va
jacques est patente au thème quand dan
lin compris qu'il voulait copier le père
noël au je suis une merde alors
qu'ils veulent à derna part de bûche
baby baby
non allez-y de toute façon je pense que
ça va être mon dernier noël
ouais je suis pas éternel à dimitri mais
au moins je vais être enterré à côté de
mamie du coup il parle un peu de vin
aussi est aussi un petit peu de foie
gras si je peux avoir salu sur monture
et enzo tondreau on se plaît enzo le
drone contrôle complet à porte dans
l'amap l'histoire de ce peuple est enfin
crevé à bord ok
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites là les enfants
chez lesquels on en septembre je fais
pitié vin blanc vin rouge et liqueurs
mais attends t'es sérieux là mec c'est
noël qu'on fait un peu autre chose
ok tequila et jet 27
[Musique]
les places pour disneyland un bmx un
book pour fumer des ouvrages pour michel
sa faillite ou la têt en pleine crise de
la quarantaine
ok donc on va vous faire tester ensemble
alors déjà une crème anti rides une
boîte de lexomil à souscrire une
assurance-vie un bien commencer un jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon les gars stanek les études j'ai pas
beaucoup de temps pour noël mais jusqu à
m'occuper du sapin ben moi je me suis
occupé du feu et moi de la bûche ça va
être énorme
chérie tu as pensé au sapin comme prévu
en fait je suis pas un retard et voilà
que tout m'est égal
bannon normalement selon la bible
saint-nicolas y avait un arbre comme ça
mais voilà les enfants chaîne contents
ils ont qu'a imaginé les enfants à ce
cas majeurs des landes
bon tout le monde a bien respecté la
règle pas plus de cinq euros le cadeau
comme ça on est tous pareils aller 3-2 à
bonbons on peut dire que c'est de la
merde c'est le pire noël de ma vie alors
les enfants qui va ouvrir ses beaux
cadeaux après qu'il va manger un bon
repas et après qui va aller à la messe
de minuit
ça c'est pas pour le petit jésus et le
petit agneau
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et
n'oubliez pas que finalement quand vient
noël on devient tous de grands enfants
merci merci mon public que j'ai invité
au montage 1 si vous voulez me faire un
cadeau pour noël
mettez tout simplement un petit tram le
tap cette vidéo et éventuellement vous
pouvez aussi cliquer sur la petite
cloche pour recevoir les notifications
afin d'être prévenu quand je sors une
nouvelle vidéo
ciao boom boom pow monsieur norman prend
les deux cadeaux à merci ça me fait très
plaisir tout ça pour moi ballon du conte
ses portes et neveux et nièces tu as 30
ans je te rappelle donc toi tu as les
chaussettes
[Musique]